-What an exciting day I had.
It's such an amazing Monday.
I went -- I was at
the White House this morning.
Hours ago,
I was at the White House.
I went -- they invited me to go
to the Easter Egg Roll.
And I go, "I would love to go."
They go, "We know you've got
the 'Nana Loves You More' book,"
and that's what
Dr. Jill Biden --
her grandkids call her Nana.
-Aww.
-I go, "This is perfect."
I go, "Great.
Will I meet the First Lady?"
They go, "Not necessarily, no."
[ Laughter ]
I go, "Okay, I'm still honored.
That would be amazing.
I'd love to go."
The girls -- I brought my kids.
And -- And so they go,
"Yeah, it's just a thing,
you'll go.
We don't know
if you'll see anyone.
It's really
the First Lady's event.
So, but you might see her,
but she has things to do."
I go, "Trust me,
I totally understand."
Went, had the best time.
Got to meet everyone.
-Oh.
-Got to meet President Biden.
I got to meet the First Lady.
I saw Ashley Biden.
It was just --
We went there, and the last time
I was at the White House,
I think was --
I did the Fourth of July --
I did some stand-up
for veterans.
And that's where
I wore like a --
I think I wore, like,
an eight-piece suit.
-Yeah.
-Because I was so excited
to meet the President
and the First Lady.
I just wanted to wear
the best suit I could wear.
It was 100 degrees,
and I was sweating.
[ Laughter ]
I looked terrible.
I looked like I was having
a stroke for the whole day.
[ Laughter ]
And I got to meet them.
And finally, the sweat
was in my collar,
and Michelle Obama was like,
"Are you all right?"
[ Laughter ]
President Obama was like,
"Didn't you get the memo?
This is a barbecue."
[ Laughter ]
And I go, "Yeah."
I go, "This time,
I'll be prepared."
I wore a nice kind of
lightweight suit.
-Right.
-Of course it was 40 degrees
in D.C. this morning.
[ Laughter ]
But I went. We went yesterday,
Easter Sunday.
I went with --
And we didn't have much time.
I wanted to go sightseeing
with Nancy and the girls.
So, we just jumped --
We got a car,
and we just jumped out,
different spots, took a photo,
or had someone take the photo,
and then ran back in the car.
[ Laughter ]
This is us at the Capitol.
No one looking at the camera
at all.
[ Laughter ]
My eyes are closed.
This is us -- it's the
Washington Monument right here.
And the Mall.
No one looking.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-No one's looking
at the camera there.
-No.
-Then I got the hang of it.
This one was good.
This one's the Lincoln --
Lincoln Memorial.
-There you go.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
-Yeah, that's everyone there.
But you -- what you realize
while you're doing this,
there's hundreds of people
looking at the Lincoln Memorial.
-Yeah.
-But now they're staring
at you, posing.
-Yeah.
-I go, "Whatever."
-Yeah, whatever.
-I don't want to take
anything away from Lincoln.
[ Laughter ]
But it was -- it was --
it was amazing.
Then I just got the hang of it.
This is just a nice --
a nice thing of us there.
-Aww.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
-Yeah, nice.
And then this is us at the --
the White House, this morning.
And we get there --
It was just amazing.
You get to --
you get to say hi, you know,
and I go, "Oh, my gosh."
You go, "Hello,"
and they just -- President Biden
just kneeled down
and just talked to my girls
like, "I don't know
the man you're with,
but what are you guys up to?"
[ Laughter ]
All right. You know?
He was funny.
And the First Lady was amazing.
I've never met the First Lady.
Just charming
and just looked great.
And you just feel --
It's so -- It just feels --
I don't know what it is,
in D.C., in general.
If you ever get a chance,
go to D.C.
Just go to Washington, D.C.
Everything's free.
There's museums everywhere.
It's just --
Natural History Museum,
you got the Smithsonian.
-Air and Space Museum.
-Air and Space.
World War II Memor--
-Yeah.
-You get to see memorials.
It's just, honestly --
And you just go,
"God, I love this country."
It's so good.
What a beautiful, amazing --
[ Cheers and applause ]
The history of this place
is amazing.
I loved it.
I had the best time.
And I go to read the book,
I go, "Great,"
and the First Lady goes out.
She goes, "I'm gonna go out --"
Somebody said the First Lady's
going to go out and read
"Brown Bear, Brown Bear."
I go, "Awesome.
I'd love to even see that."
So she did it
in front of the kids.
And the kids are all laughing.
It was, like -- amazing, like,
educational-themed,
but fun family thing for the --
for, like, the kids.
And then,
she was supposed to leave.
And then, the President
comes and sits next to her.
So, then
they're both sitting there,
and then I thought
they were both gonna leave.
Then they go,
"We'll stay for Jimmy."
And so they just stayed,
and we read "Nana"
to all these kids
with the President.
He was like --
and the First Lady's like --
Because, you know, it's me.
So I'm just like -- I'm --
I don't even consider myself,
really, an author.
But I'm reading this book.
And she's going,
"I love this book."
And I was like,
"Put her mic up."
[ Laughter ]
"This is fantastic.
This is a great endorsement
or my book."
They could not
have been nicer humans.
And everyone was great.
What a great vibe from there.
I just want to thank
the White House so much
for inviting me.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Go check out D.C.
if you want to go on vacation.
It's a beautiful place.